the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
tonight on politics now russia invades
ukraine the u.s response and the
economic ripple effects being felt here
plus
i don't think that we we cross a
threshold of justifying
you know american troop deployment
republican senate candidate and wounded
veteran sam brown talks to us about the
russian invasion and his plans if he's
elected to tackle inflation
i will always support strong parent
participation in making our education
system the best it can be
an off-year state of the state speech
governor steve sisilak lays out his
plans to spend nearly two billion
dollars in federal funding and not raise
taxes
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we start
though with the history making nominee
friday president joe biden announced his
selection to fill an open seat on the
u.s supreme court it is federal appeals
court judge katanji brown jackson she's
a harvard law school graduate and a
former clerk for retiring justice
stephen breyer president biden had
promised to nominate a black woman to
that post senate democrats plan to move
quickly for a vote ahead of the midterm
elections senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell congratulated her on the
nomination and then added she was the
quote favored choice of far left dark
money groups
we'll continue to watch that moving
forward but now to russia's full-scale
invasion of ukraine after weeks of
threats this week it finally happened
drawing condemnation from the western
world after the initial invasion russia
fired roughly a hundred missiles at
ukraine's military infrastructure highly
populated areas targeted as well
president joe biden announced new
economic sanctions to maximize a
long-term impact on russia
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
today i'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions
and new limitations on what can be
exported to russia
meanwhile nato says it will activate
defense plans to protect its eastern
flank remember ukraine is not in nato
around 7 000 additional u.s troops will
deploy to germany in the coming days
americans were bracing for the economic
impact of russia's invasion stock market
tumbled earlier in the week then
recovered as analysts are trying to read
the impact on prices here at home elise
preston has the painful ripple effects
americans woke to the site of war in
europe as russia launched its invasion
of ukraine and the shock waves may be on
their way here to the pump where drivers
are already facing the highest prices in
years are you concerned that it's going
to keep getting worse yeah it probably
will i wouldn't be surprised if it does
russia supplies 10 percent of the
world's oil and the prospect of
disruptions has driven the price over
100 dollars a barrel for the first time
since 2014. it's pushing gas prices up
past six dollars a gallon in los angeles
county with the national average already
at 354 a gallon i was shocked to see the
prices beyond the pain at the pump
higher gas prices can have a significant
impact on the broader economy
translating to less travel less eating
out and less shopping with inflation
already at the highest level in decades
the crisis could affect everything from
automakers to grocery stores we also
could see agricultural prices for wheat
and corn because russia and ukraine are
big exporters and finally we could see
metal prices when we look at iron ore we
look at palladium used in those chips
that we need in cars the white house is
watching but says larger issues are at
stake standing up for our values is not
without cost
what we're trying to do is minimize that
cost rattled stock investors took a
roller coaster ride the dow jones
industrial average lost 800 points at
the open before rebounding on the upside
as traders contemplate what could be
europe's biggest land war since world
war ii elise preston cbs news new york
and again the stock market a roller
coaster ride all week down earlier up on
friday it's been a wild ride nevada's
congressional delegation all have
supported these economic sanctions and
all condemned the actions of russia
one of the republicans running to
challenge nevada senator catherine
cortez masto is wounded warrior sam
brown he was a captain in afghanistan
this week i spoke with him about
russia's invasion combating inflation
and schools we started with what to do
in ukraine
americans need to understand that
people like me are not about just
throwing troops into conflicts without
any sort of real justification
and so with ukraine's uh having just
been invaded now by russia
this is a case where i don't think that
we we cross a threshold of justifying
you know american troop deployment
but it's
things it's a very complicated situation
and things get muddled um you know just
in short little sound bites or you know
tweets or whatever
the the challenges here
are that
we've got a
people that sort of assume that ukraine
is part of nato and we have obligations
to nato
but those don't extend to the ukraine if
you were in the senate right now what
would you say to your fellow senators to
to the white house
to avoid being
distracted
i would say that we would need to
keep our eye on china uh right now and
and like i think that you know russia's
signals and specifically putin's are
that you know sanctions don't seem to be
a deterrence to them
and so you know it's it's sort of uh you
know just this political
dog and pony show
but
keep keep your ammo dry look to the
future any sort of you know deterrence
that could have prevented russia from
crossing the border of ukraine that
moment's already gone so look to the
future and say what do we need to do to
deter china from having a similar action
in taiwan
let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about uh the race for senate obviously
you're not the only republican running
adam laxalt is running as well and a lot
of the nevada republican establishment
seems to have put their their weight
behind him financially at least uh what
kind of support
have you received um to try and make
sure that you're the person who runs uh
for the senate for the republican side
yeah it's interesting that you know you
would kind of couch it as the
the establishment you disagree yeah i i
would sort of
disagree in this regard that um
adam has had
by his own fec accounts uh fewer than
600 itemized contributions from nevadans
fewer than 600.
think about that
contrasted to i've had thousands of
nevadans who've donated to me in this
campaign so this is the true grassroots
campaign this is the campaign for
working class nevadans for working
families for people who want to see
change if you're in the senate what
would you do to start trying to tackle
inflation yeah so
so inflation is largely contributed by
by two things one is congressional
spending you know
congress just uh passed this you know
short-term spending uh continuing
resolution which
you know
right then and they're like
they've lost accountability to their
purpose it's not like there's a surprise
that they should be coming up with a
budget and passing it every year and so
the fact that we just continue to have
continuing resolutions is a failure of
itself
but congress has got to cut spending
because the excessive spending coming
out of out of congress is leading to
inflation but another contributor to
that is the central bank the fed is
dumping tons of liquidity into the
market and that's driving up
the inflation as well which is a big
word that a lot of politicians use but
what does that mean it means higher
costs in the grocery stores higher
energy costs
it's it's it's people having to make
tough choices you mentioned opposition
to critical race theory on your uh your
political website how much of critical
race theory do you think
is being taught in nevada right now and
what's an example
so let's use washable county as an
example that's where you know it's where
i live and and i know the school
district you know better
critical race theory has not been taught
on ace on a school district level
yet there were attempts last year to
adopt curriculum that included critical
craze theory but critical race theory
could also
be be known as something that they call
social and emotional learning as well
and so
my
my hope is that we have school districts
that are that are one much more locally
controlled than than you know having a
federal
you know influence
but that
as long as we're still ranked at you
know 49th in the nation and at least one
of the recent rankings
let's focus on reading writing
arithmetic
you can watch our full interview with
captain sam brown on 8newsnow.com
brown's republican primary challenger
for senate is former attorney general
adam laxalt he was in florida at
mar-a-lago doing a fundraiser with
former president donald trump this week
laxalt tweeted a picture of him with mr
trump there you see it there at his club
in palm beach florida this was on
tuesday friday black salt spoke at the
cpac conference in orlando
now to the governor's race a pro joe
lombardo super pac has a new ad out
in steve sisilax nevada criminals are
free to walk our streets and it's harder
for police to do their jobs
better nevada pack made a six-figure ad
buy with the spot the commercial you're
seeing right here goes on to say sheriff
lombardo's nevada is safer and more
secure that's the claim from the ad
lombardo seen as something of the
current front-runner in the republican
primary race for governor
no legislative session this year of
course still this week governor steve
sisilak held a state of the state speech
he wanted to use a legion stadium as the
backdrop unfortunately nobody told
metallica the band was setting up a
stage below the podium where the
governor was supposed to be told all the
media to turn the cameras around still
the governor's speech carried on just
like his spending plan for the year
governor steve sisilak is running for
reelection and he hasn't really
campaigned yet nevada is on the move
today's state of the state had all the
signs of a campaign speech with a 1.9
billion dollar check attached we're
believers
we believe that problems can be solved
that big things can be accomplished
governor sisalek outlined a massive
spending proposal
no new taxes
no new taxes money comes from the
federal government's american rescue
plan it includes the state's largest
investment in affordable housing ever
the plan boosts housing construction
improving education i will always
support strong parent participation in
making our education system the best it
can be bumping pay for nevada state
police i would be proposing a salary
increase hundreds of millions of dollars
will go to roads paying for a year of
free school lunches and boosting small
business our government faltered when
our residents needed it most during the
pandemic state senate republican leader
james settlemyer governor syslock may
think that 6.7 billion dollars from the
federal government is enough to fix the
state and he would be wrong still the
governor struck an optimistic tone he's
confident the legislature and voters
will follow his lead ultimately this is
about making life better for the people
we love
most of the governor's proposals have to
be approved by the interim finance
committee which is of course led by
democrats meanwhile the election that's
254 days from now
next on politics now a focus on
education the secretary of education is
in las vegas touring nevada schools how
he wants to attract more teachers plus
the new standards for substitute
teachers we'll tell you how nevada's
trying to make sure that classrooms have
enough education
or try them bacon loaded for 450.
welcome back to politics now
months ago clark county school board
members voted to fire then voted to
bring back afterwards superintendent dr
jesus jarrah well now the board is
giving him new goals for the upcoming
school year first improve proficiency in
reading for students in grade three and
math for grades six through eight second
lessen the number of black and african
american students suspended or expelled
and finally hire more than sixteen
hundred teachers before november first
superintendent jara says he is confident
ccsd can get those tasks done
u.s education secretary miguel cardona
was in las vegas this week he visited
several schools including clark high
secretary cardona also announced 800
million dollars in federal funding for
ccsd christian cosmetics reports
the students were a little freaked out
because there was like cameras in our
face but they did well
clark high school students spent part of
their school day with u.s secretary of
education miguel cardona and
congresswoman dina titus
the visit was to get a first hand look
at how students were handling the return
to the classroom after remote learning
and a better picture of the importance
of extracurricular
too come activities so important now
knowing that the pandemic has robbed
students of opportunities to
engage with their peers
and develop those skills so hearing
directly from the students how important
the funding that goes to our districts
is so that these activities continue as
a group of leaders explored the campus
on arville and pennwood they dropped in
during class time and sat on lectures
later they held a discussion with these
students about their experience with
school activities but the bigger concern
was staffing shortages use the american
rescue plan funds to incentivize
getting educators to stay in the
profession but also let's consider
bringing back retired teachers cardona
says a long-term solution to get more
teachers in the future was already in
the works at this high school
if you can be a teacher
first time i walked into a classroom of
high school students who are studying to
become teachers
led by a teacher that's getting them
connected to unlv
for now activities like music are
expected to be enhanced by the funding
and help bring a sense of normalcy back
teachers say from the pandemic
extracurriculars is a big thing i hope
you know budgets stay maybe even grow
christian casa is live local now
the money will be dished out once it
actually gets from the federal
government to clark county school
district
state education leaders are trying to
find a way to make it easier to put
substitute teachers in the classroom
some new rules approved this week will
allow those with a high school diploma
to apply for a teaching license all you
need is that high school diploma this
would only apply though during an
emergency declaration which we're in
right now because of the pandemic mary
jane belliesa reports
nevada department of education wants to
make this permanent but there are
concerns about how qualified applicants
are with just a high school diploma and
limited training it's been an ongoing
problem even before the pandemic not
enough teachers and not enough
substitutes kenny belknap with the
commission and educator at liberty high
school says emergency substitute
teachers need more training i find it
troubling especially with these
emergency sub licenses that we're saying
it's okay that someone with a high
school equivalent diploma can serve as a
long-term sub someone who can serve in a
classroom with you know 40 plus kids for
an entire school year teaching them the
content area that they need under this
emergency declaration
and
you know there's no accountability the
commission has provided accountability
recommendations suggesting subs
routinely meet with administrators and
undergo an evaluation process
commissioner jordan wenger agrees with
this proposal i'm just really concerned
that these emergency substitutes are
being used in our title one schools more
frequently
and those are our kids that are
need the best instruction so i want to
make sure that this regulation
is
giving them that accountability
of getting the best teachers in there
that are qualified currently there are
600 emergency subs in clark and washoe
county school districts these subs will
be teaching for the remainder of the
school year and next year if nevada
remains under a state of emergency i
look at the emergency situation right
now it's a temporary thing we're doing a
lot it looks like we're doing a
long-term fix to a temporary problem
i think a real fix to this is the
district's really looking at what
they're doing with their subs providing
better pay incentivizing people to work
for them rather than relying on state
regulations mary jane valeeza live local
now
the state commission also approved a
motion to meet again in the spring and
they'll discuss extending training for
those subs to eight hours to try and
increase teacher accountability
a new audit points out some major
problems in nevada's department of
corrections the report made public this
week says the doc paid excessive
overtime inappropriately assigned
state-owned vehicles and over charged
prisoners
prison chief charles daniels pushed back
on the overtime criticism he says
increased workloads leave him without
many choices
some of the excessive charging of
prisoners cited were for medical copays
and hygiene products like soap and
deodorant
next on politics now trying to slow down
inflation we'll look at a new plan for
our ports in the u.s the biden
administration hopes can solve supply
chain issues
plus why a proposed gas tax holiday
wouldn't actually lower your gas bill at
all this is 8 news now
welcome back to politics now
unanimous ruling by nevada's supreme
court will force southwest gas to
justify its rate hikes to consumers
comes on the heels of rate hikes that
have caused some bills to double now it
had been up to regulators and rate
payers to justify why hikes shouldn't be
passed along to them well this flips
that dynamic it also upholds a previous
ruling requiring utilities to justify
hikes to the public utilities commission
and ratepayers
a gas tax holiday backed by nevada's two
senators turns out won't actually lower
your gas costs at all the idea would
eliminate the federal gas tax for a year
however nevada actually has a law that
says if the federal gas tax is
eliminated the state gas tax just is
increased to cover the difference so
when you go to fill up it's going to
cost about the same
efforts to slow down inflation meanwhile
they continue the transportation
department announced new grants federal
grants to upgrade our ports alexander
limon spoke with the transportation
secretary about the investments that he
says will relieve the pressure
hundreds of millions of dollars are set
up to upgrade american ports to fund
improvements from adding capacity to
linking rail into our our port network
anything that will help goods move more
efficiently in this country the 450
million dollars in grants come from the
bipartisan infrastructure law and
secretary of transportation pete
buttigieg says the upgrades to ports
will tackle the supply chain problems
caused by the coronavirus pandemic fix
decades of under investments and provide
much needed upgrades to handle modern
ships sometimes even in our biggest
ports a whole new channel has to be
dredged to a deeper level or a bridge
has to be replaced because these ships
are so big they can't fit under it
secretary budej says these investments
are necessary for the u.s to remain a
world leader and ultimately to help
lower the prices of goods but the
physical infrastructure upgrades could
take years to complete buddha judge says
that's why the administration is also
working on more immediate solutions
pushing toward 24 7 operations setting
up things like temporary pop-up
container yards to clear some of the
containers inland when there's not
enough room in the ports themselves
buddhitage says another effort to
resolve supply chain problems is a push
by the administration to produce more
things domestically in washington
alexandra alimon
laying out a plan for the country next
on politics now what president joe biden
is expected to talk about next week's
state of the union
three three three three
[Music]
welcome back next week in what to watch
president joe biden gives his state of
the union address the address will be on
wednesday of course we will carry it
live right here on channel 8. the
president is expected to certainly talk
about the russian invasion of ukraine
ongoing inflation has stalled build back
better legislation voting rights and
climate change
iowa republican governor kim reynolds
will give the republican rebuttal and
minnesota congresswoman rashida talib
will be giving a rebuttal for the
working families party all coming up
this week
we thank you so much for watching us
here on politics now all the political
news you need eight newsnow dot com
we're back with you on saturday thank
you for watching take care
[Music]
[Music]
you